hi there everyone this is some extra
footage from our nitrogen triiodide
video again showing as we often do that
things don't always go according to plan
in the chemistry lab now in the original
video you probably saw this
[Applause]
we have a lego professor touching some
dried-out nitrogen triiodide it's a
contact explosive so the result is
obvious all very nice filmed very
carefully now often we decided to film
these experiments a second time mainly
so I can get better footage because I
don't do a very good job the first time
so here we are in the lab we're going to
do it a second time we've got some wet
nitrogen triiodide on the hot plate but
it's getting me at the end of the day we
have to go home and when we first give
it a try as you can see no reaction the
chemicals are still too wet they haven't
dried out now we've got them on a hot
plate to help them dry out and you can
see here we're trying to increase the
temperature I think it was originally at
something like 50 degrees Celsius we go
for a hundred and then decide no that's
too much go back down to 75 because we
don't want the heat itself to cause the
reaction to happen now here we are just
waiting around for things to dry out and
by I think more luck than anything I
have got the high-speed cameras still
running ready to trigger and all the
lights are still on and that's a good
thing because mid-conversation suddenly
we get this
and I guess just reflexively when the
reaction went off I did press the
trigger and capture the slow motion here
it is nothing setting it off except just
the hate but if we look at that again
here's where we see a small problem we
have some still wet nitrogen triiodide
off to the side here being blown to the
side of the fume hood that means we have
small specks of wet nitrogen triiodide
in Neil's fume hood if you've watched
our videos before you know this is not
the first time we've made a mess of the
fume hood but the problem here is it's
still wet and when it dries it's ready
to go again so Neil got his little Lego
man and started setting off the bits of
nitrogen triiodide as they dried
it'll snap crackle and pop slight rice
bubbles we also noticed a few little
specks on the floor around the fume hood
they were mainly being set off by my
shoes and of course the equipment that's
in the fume hood may have had small
specks on it as well so knew had to get
all of that out and give it a good
seeing - there you go not everything
goes to plan in the chemistry lab but
it's always good that you see that as
well